la parole est à madame marie jo
zimmermann merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargée du droit des femmes
il y a deux semaines notre collègue
valérie boyer a déjà interrogé le
gouvernement laissons les incidents
extrêmement graves qui se sont déroulés
à cologne en europe
l'ampleur du problème dépasse ce que
l'on pouvait imaginer et je tiens à
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
malheureusement beaucoup de migrants ne
partagent pas notre conception du droit
des femmes il faut dire la vérité je
regrette qu'il ait fallu plus d'une
semaine pour que les événements de
cologne soit connue et servent de
catalyseur en brisant l'omerta qui pèse
sur le sujet nous sommes confrontés
brutalement la réalité il est clair que
l'arrivée massive d'une population
étrangère fragilisé n'ayant pas les
mêmes valeurs de vie en société que nous
conduit à une rupture
c'est d'autant plus préoccupant qu'il y
ait écrit l écrasante majorité d'hommes
parmi ces arrivants selon les
statistiques 2015 de l'organisation
internationale de l'immigration il n'y
avait que 13 % de femmes pour 69 %
d'hommes 18 % de mineurs dont 90 % de
jeunes adolescents madame la ministre
il faut prendre en compte les problèmes
humains qu'ils se posent
mais il faut aussi garantir la sécurité
de nos concitoyennes cela doit être même
une priorité absolue on ne peut attendre
que ce qui s'est passé à cologne et dans
d'autres pays européens se passe demain
à kehl et qui est une véritable bombe à
retardement ou se passe ailleurs que
dans nos villes nos villages
ma question est donc simple madame la
ministre quelle est la situation en
france
notre pays est reconnu dans le monde
entier comme un mort un modèle pour le
droit des femmes
nous y avons tous et toutes dans un
temps cette assemblée collectivement
contribuer madame la ministre prouve on
nous a accepté de fermer les yeux sur
une réalité qui risque de nous exploser
à la figure
merci merci madame superman la parole
est à mme pascale boitard secrétaire
d'état chargée des droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée zimmermann permettez moi de vous
dire que là le sujet des violences
faites aux femmes vous l'avez dit
vous-même est une préoccupation de
premier plan pour le gouvernement
quels que soient les auteurs et je le
répète ici
il doit être évidemment poursuivi est
punie parce que le viol est un crime
parce que les agressions sexuelles sont
des délits et quels que soient les
auteurs il doit être donc condamnés nous
sommes dans notre pays effectivement sur
ce sujet des droits des femmes à la
pointe
je dirais de du sujet qui concerne les
femmes dans l'espace public
c'est un espace qui doit être un espace
de liberté
un espace partagé et je dirais même un
espace de respect et c'est pour ça que
nous travaillons chaque jour et vous le
savez puisque vous faites partie des
députés qui contribuent à ces réflexions
à l'élaboration de ces dispositifs est
bien de faire en sorte que et bien les
femmes et toute leur place soit libre
indépendante de vivre comme elle le
souhaite sans qu'il y ait de joux de qui
que ce soit sur leur mode de vie et
c'est un enjeu majeur
c'est un enjeu majeur parce que nous
pouvons estimer évidemment la société la
qualité je dirais de vie dans une
société à la hauteur justement de ces
situations
ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé
dans d'autres pays européens nous
interroge tous évidemment nous sommes
dans un premier temps sous l'émotion
l'effroi et c'est pour ça que nous
souhaitons ne pas abandonner nos
politiques publiques et au contraire les
renforcer comme nous l'avons fait dans
les transports je vous remercie de cette
question parce que moi vous vous n'avez
pas fait de cette question une polémique
politiciens
si madame la ministre la parole est à m